hi there Steve Kaufman day 13 very busy
now with my hockey tournament and so
forth and of course tomorrow morning I
have to take my wife to the hospital for
six thirty so i have to get up quite
early and then i have to pick her up but
it's basically a bunion operations on a
big deal except that she will be sedated
and it's very painful apparently and
remains painful and so for her it would
be a long period of before she'll be
able to get back on her two feet but of
course my team is concerned about the
game we have a game at 12 45 and it'll
be touch and go as to whether i can get
her home and then get to the rink in
time for the game one of the guys
suggested that i had take her to the
game and use the hov high occupancy
vehicle lane that was the joke by the
way we all laughed in the dressing room
my wife live to but i'm not sure she
appreciated the joke so no no can't do
that so very busy these days with that
going on and of course trying to stay on
top of my korean someone asks how much
do I listen like I'm listening to this
podcast it's about people abusing
Twitter this guy abusing Twitter
retweeting stuff setting up BOTS to
retweet and put pressure on people and
that this was in violation of the
election campaigning regulations in
Korea and so this kim jong bay had two
people on representing two different
points of view very civilized discussion
very interesting how much to understand
when i read it having now looked up all
the words i understand it when i listen
to it my comprehension drops down to
about fifty percent however i am getting
the rhythm of the language i'm getting
the rhythm of the structure of how they
say things and i'm full of this
confidence that i will eventually be
able to speak with that rhythm and use
the words the way they use them even
though my comprehension isn't quite
there so i've been listening I've
listened to it now six seven eight times
because I want to try to get better at
this particular text but now at the
point where it's too boring so I'm going
to move on to a new text create new
links and do the same with it and over
time the same structure the same pattern
some of the same words will come back at
me and I am confident that I will get
better so and I should make a confession
here I'm not a big fan for example of
when I go into that bookstore you know I
could like Moses have a camera on my
head and try and say something in Korean
to the saleslady and get the usual
compliments on my Korean and stuff but I
know that I'm not that good and I gave
the impression that I'm good but in fact
I'm not and so I'm not that interest in
doing it I would rather wait till I have
a better level that a level of
comprehension and then I have meaningful
discussions with people I'm not so
that's why I haven't done that I may go
and visit my friend Lee dry cleaner and
speak in Korean later but it's not a big
priority for me one other quick thing to
touch on again I mean the sort of I'm
confessing on things here people ask me
have you used glossy got glass ekkada
this is mike campbell i think who lives
in taiwan or lived in Taiwan who speaks
beautiful Mandarin and a number of other
languages and has developed a system
which seems to be very popular and have
I tried it in the answer is no I haven't
tried it I am NOT tremendously motivated
that's not to say that it doesn't work
that is good it all depends on your
goals but apparently he has developed
3,000 sentences in these different
languages and if you study these
sentences through some system presumably
some kind of spaced repetition system
then now you have these structures these
sentences we have vocabulary and you are
ready to speak I have a limited amount
of time that I can spend on language
learning I would rather listen to this
interesting content i'm learning about
issues in korea a little bit about the
culture how they defend themselves and i
was just curious i looked up my
statistics and i have read 270,000 words
in korean probably i have listened to an
equivalent equivalent amount that's an
awful lot if the average sentence is 15
words long if we can round the 2 i'll be
at 300,000 so that's what ever it is
20,000 sentences that I've been exposed
to now I haven't practiced them so that
I can then regurgitate them but that is
not my goal
my goal is to get to her I can't
comprehend so I have this at least
passive vocabulary of thirty-five
thousand words which I wouldn't achieve
if I focused on just being able to
reproduce 3000 sentences that's not to
say that that isn't a good thing to aim
for if that's what your goal is so I
think the key thing in language learning
is to enjoy what you're doing spend the
time and do the things that you like to
do do those things that meet your goals
so I have my goals studying here in
Vancouver if I lived in Korea and I had
a more urgent need to be able to speak
well in the language I might take a
different approach I might in fact look
into the classical approach so thank you
live now